from early-morning betrayals to
late-night drug deals we're driving
straight into all the drama on
Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes I'm Liana
Galera your jug head loving host and
this is the Sweetwater Secrets
after-show for episode 206 chapter 19
death Proof so if you have not seen the
episode make a u-turn away from your
screens and speed out of here ASAP just
be sure to avoid with lurking and dead
man's curve now this week I'm breaking
down the most shocking romance
revelations of the week yep I'm talking
about you Tony topaz and Madeline patch
is spilling behind the scenes scoop
about Cheryl's most terrifying moment
from the episode and it's not what you
may think so let's jump right into the
top headlines of the week in the blue
and gold breakdown all right guys first
up we had a drag race in this episode so
just like Judy no not that kind of drag
race whoa no she bothered Oh
now after seeking advice from his dad
Jughead embraced his role as a circuit
Prince and made a deal with the Ghoulies
whichever gang wins the race gets
control of the south side so everyone
was pumped for the greased inspired
moment but just as Jughead was about to
embrace his inner Danny Zuko and feel
the win
Archie pulled the brakes literally on
the whole deal now to be honest it was
kind of a [ __ ] move for Archie to call
the cops and I'm worried that Jughead
won't be the one who'll have to pay next
up the black hood took a bit of a
backseat to all the high-speed drama but
he's still forced Betty to discover the
identity of the sugar man now this is
the mysterious drug dealer who took over
for Clifford blossom and is supplying
the south side with jingle jangle Cheryl
eventually got the truth from her
pathetic excuse of a mother and Betty
chose to betray the black hood and take
back the power I'm breathing down your
neck
can you feel it so who's the sugar man
it's that random smarmy teacher from
Southside high proving that all teachers
in Riverdale are seriously disturbed oh
well looks like the black hood took care
of it anyways oh and in case any of you
guys were wondering which none of you
were Nick Sinclair and is so stupid I
really want to punch him face walked out
of Riverdale unharmed that is until he
was involved in a car accident on his
way out of town
Karma's a [ __ ] moving on all right guys
it was a roller coaster ride of emotions
with the Riverdale relationships in this
week's seven seconds in heaven now once
again barchi served at some serious
relationship goals with those bedroom
cuddles but the moment that everyone is
screaming about is Tony sleeping over a
jugheads place last night was a pg-13
group session no not cool but try not to
freak out too much bug-head fans they
didn't sleep together in fact Tony made
her intentions pretty damn clear I'm
Lorent across anyways now I was really
happy to see that Riverdale confirmed
that Tony is indeed bisexual but I was
left with so many questions which leads
us straight into this week's kisses and
kisses all right guys first up kisses to
the fact that I am so confused is bug
head really back together did Jughead
tell Betty about his sleepover with Tony
I doubt it but honestly I really don't
want to have to see her make this face
again it was seriously so heartbreaking
I'm just really frustrated with jugg
right now and this hat is really hot and
the lights are bright in here and I just
have a lot of feelings pisses to Archie
for going behind jugheads back and
squealing to the cops about the race and
the biggest hiss of all goes to Cheryl's
mom for victim shaming her own daughter
Cheryl is all you have left in this
world and all she wants is to be loved
so stop being such a [ __ ] perish her
come on alright guys moving into kisses
that one is going straight to Betty and
Veronica for making up and teaming up in
their quest for the sugar man B&B for
life and kisses for more LGBTQIA
representation in Riverdale with the
confirmation that Tony is bi
sexual oh and kisses to these flirty
eyes between Josie and Reggie watch me
walk away huh kiss mr. Kevin tell her
for being his perfect self and to the
amazing fifties inspired fashion in this
episode especially to share a blossom
placation look and her diva moment at
the drag race not today ChaCha
I was born for this moment but here's
what the lovely Madeline patch had to
Tommy about Cheryl's most fabulous
moments in this week's episode your
fashions in Episode six though are
amazing I mean iconic iconic let's talk
about the sunbathing scene between you
and Betty so amazing when you read the
script were you like okay
I mean it was written in the script that
I was in a red swimsuit with a big
floppy hat and got like I'm not kidding
you with sunglasses on like they're like
this is the vision but also spent the
most pale person who ever Dale is the
one who's going into the Sun like come
on
also your outfit at the drag race scene
when you do a fitting you have like
three options for an outfit for Electra
ticular scenes and so you never know
which one you're gonna walk into a
dressing room and see and I opened my
dressing-room door that day knowing
something was gonna be behind it and I
was so excited but it's so epic it was
so hot that day too but so good yeah it
was actually close by shots and stuff
Cheryl slight disc two Tony was amazing
step aside Jojo I got this that's the
line they kept it I did like ten Ulta
member how many times did you practice I
was terrified though to be fair because
I have to stay very still cuz two real
cars raced past me with this much room
on either side of me you know when they
all start running after it to turn
around and I was like this it made me
want to get a scarf I'm just like yes
Queen yes yes fine Michelle yes
play all day Cheryl alright vixens now
that does it for this week's Sweetwater
secrets after-show and now I am dying to
know your thoughts hit the comments
below to confess all of your kisses and
kisses from chapter 19 and tell me your
thoughts on the status of bug heads
relationship are they together
should they be together what's going on
tell me alright guys please give this
video a like and subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel and then ring the bell
in the link below so you never miss an
episode of Sweetwater secrets see
timer boo babe
[Music]
you